move over lannisters a house of the
dragon scene has taken us back to the
ickiest days of game of thrones warning
the spoilers ahead for house of the
dragon episode 4.
if that scene in the depths of king's
landing's underworld grossed you out
you're not alone but the actors involved
were apparently just fine with it in the
fourth episode of this brand new hit
game of thrones spin-off from hbo
princess rhaenyra targaryen played in
her youth by millie alcock ends up
exploring the underbelly of king's
landing with her troublemaking uncle
damon who takes her beyond the walls of
the red keep for a stealthy night on the
town
after taking in a crude show about the
targaryen line of succession which
paints rhaenyra and a pretty
unflattering light and several drinks
the two abscond to a brothel together
which gets pretty weird pretty quickly
daemon escorts his knees through the
crowded establishment taking in scenes
of people in various compromising
positions before assuming one himself a
passionate kiss with his own niece
rhaenyra responds however and the two
really start to go at it before damon
demures apparently in part due to
performance issues which he's dealt with
in previous episodes the scene may have
been pretty uncomfortable to watch in
multiple levels but according to alcock
it was kind of a breeze to actually film
speaking to the new york post alcock
said the scene was surprisingly routine
to shoot thanks to coordinators behind
the scenes as well as their solid
off-screen relationship with smith an
industry veteran who's appeared in
everything from doctor who to morbius as
alcock told the post smith and i were
just kind of mates so it was quite
comfortable we had an intimacy
coordinator and we worked with her
through the rehearsal process and
blocked it out months before that said
there was one major surprise the brothel
itself alcock continued claire kilner
our director made sure that we hadn't
seen any of the brothel stuff until we
were shooting so that was our first time
walking through the brothel and he's
guiding her through the room with all of
these other bodies so that was quite
shocking you're like this is kind of
weird and silly there were extras who we
had just met who were like 69 for 12
hours it's pretty gnarly we felt pretty
overdressed because everyone else was
nude directing scenes like that can be
really difficult it's a big
responsibility and it's important to
shoot it from the right point of view
clearly alcock and smith were put as at
ease as possible during this tricky
scene even with the inherent weirdness
of their surroundings during this
pivotal moment as a predecessor to house
of the dragon hbo's juggernaut game of
thrones drew plenty of controversy due
to its often brutal depictions of sexual
violence against women and it seems that
house of the dragon may be taking a
different approach particularly in
episode 4. when rhaenyra is left high
and dry after her encounter with damon
she returns home only to seduce sir
kristin cole taking complete control in
the encounter and savouring every minute
of it house of the dragon also shows the
other side of the coin in this episode
with allison hightower the second wife
and queen to rhaenyra's father king
viserys expected to be available any
time the king requests alison is awoken
in the middle of the night for one of
his visits and is depicted as
emotionless and vacant during the act
itself now it's not a violent scene it's
an unsettling portrayal of what it looks
like to as a woman in a medieval era
forgo your personal boundaries and
pleasure as part of a patriarchal
structure like an absolute monarchy in
any case it does seem like the actors on
set for house of the dragon are well
protected behind the scenes no matter
how controversial those scenes are
[Music]